and so once we get past kind of those
studies so I think of studies maybe
correctly or incorrectly as the way to
gather data
we're like what are the milestones or
kind of the stamps of approval like what
does that look like is that the people
who run the study saying hey stamp of
approval this works is there some kind
of overarching like governing body or
government organization what is that
kind of approval process look like
before it can actually start being given
to patients kind of on the ground yeah
you so there's basically two different
ways to either have to come to the FDA
with sufficient evidence to show that
this medication is safe and beneficial
in its treatment of a specific disease
that's the if you want to call on lethal
use so that's you know what the
prescription is designed for it's a
doctors also have the option though to
use medicines off-label which means this
is not the FDA approved indication for
it but doctors still have the ability to
prescribe medications where they think
appropriate are necessary in patients
that it's not the the specific
indication that the FDA approves this is
where things get interesting though
because in America medicine is fairly
limited just so of you as a physician
deviate from that standard of care and
then something goes wrong even if that
something went wrong was a small percent
and that could happen to either you know
someone with an FDA approved indication
it still makes you vulnerable to a
lawsuit and traditionally its academic
physicians or people or physicians are
very comfortable experimenting with new
use cases for these drugs and we'll see
those patients the problem we're seeing
in a pandemic is those physicians those
academic ones they kind of becoming
overwhelmed you have patients all over
so it's not just a very rare case of
something we're looking for a position
that will we'll treat this thing with a
softly off-label use you have physicians
everywhere that are kind of stuck in
this thing where do I use a certain
medication off-label for to treat all
these coronavirus patients that are
coming into my ward or do I just give
them IV fluids and you know hopefully
get better and that's I think the
a lot of positions in the US are dealing
with right now and so they're looking
for some guidance from the FDA
essentially saying hey you can use which
that's what kind of what Trump did a
little bit today react t I think back on
that a little bit but he essentially
said look I'm approving people for
approving physicians to use the this
medication hydroxychloroquine in
coronavirus patients I don't know if
it's really that hard of a that that
really passed through it I think there's
still some red tape that maybe needs to
go through but that's essentially I
think what he's aiming it yeah it's
really interesting to see a lot of kind
of bureaucracies and red tape in the
health care system being almost broken
down in this crisis right so everything
from what you're talking about kind of
the acceleration or approval process to
you know the ability for a doctor to
actually administer health care services
to a patient in a different state right
a lot of telemedicine stuff etc for
those that aren't aware of how
bureaucratic healthcare is there's a lot
of rules that - I think you kind of
mentioned earlier make sense sometimes
other times they seem really stupid
right and so it takes a crisis like this
to kind of break some of those down and
then maybe some of them get reinstated
later or maybe they don't but but it's
just been fascinating to me to kind of
watch this almost tennis match between
here's the rules today well should we
keep them or is this kind of an
emergency situation let's get rid of
them yeah exactly you kind of take a
hard look and say wait which of these
rules are actually high-yield and which
ones are just you know vestiges of old
bureaucracy of it is maybe doodle
obvious sir who knows